Like artists,
filmmakers have a unique set of tools at
their disposal,
cameras,
lenses,
lights,
microphones,
music,
and they use these tools to tell their
story or set a scene.
The director,
David Lynch has of course the same tools
as everybody else,
but lynch manipulates more than just
these physical instruments more deeply
and more strangely than any other
director I know of.
He uses expectation as a tool.
He wields expectation,
the expectation that comes from what we
know about film,
about its history,
the history of stories,
and from our humanity with the same
nuance and power and someone else might
use light to create a variety of moods
in a space.
Today I want to look at how Lynch
manipulates our expectations in a single
scene from his masterpiece.
Mulholland drive the guidance towards
some interesting emotional territory.
Let's scene I'm talking about is one of
my favorite ever.
The audition scene where betty played by
Naomi Watts,
tries out for a part in a small movie.
We later learn is called the Sylvia
North Story.
The scene occurs about halfway through
the film.
Betty has come to Hollywood bright eyed
and bushy tailed to be a movie star.
Oh,
of course.
I'd rather be known as a great actress
than a movie star,
but you know,
sometimes people end up being both.
She's staying at her aunt's house where
she discovers Rita,
a woman who's been in a car accident and
has lost all her memory or expectations
for the audition have already been set
up by much of what we've witnessed
leading up to the scene.
Betty doesn't seem to be a character
with much internal depth or darkness or
flatness of affect is even parodied in
her very first scene at the airport
where the dialogue is clearly overdubbed
and fake.
Okay,
Irene,
the day her blind kindness makes her
vulnerable to exploitation.
She doesn't even really care that a
stranger is living in her aunt's house.
So coming into the audition were feeling
a couple of things were somewhat
invested in Betty success.
A basic expectation for any protagonist,
but we're wary of some danger that may
be in store because of her innocence and
we have little or no expectation that
she will impress with her acting chops.
Why don't you join woody over there and
we'll play the scene,
and of course the last thing to mention
is that we've already seen this scene
played out once before back at the house
or a practice round,
a tryout for a trial with betty and
Rita.
You're still here.
I came back.
I thought that's what you wanted.
Nobody wants you here in this first
reading.
The scene is revealed to be trite,
the dialogue cliched and melodramatic,
but he's character rebukes her father's
friend who is trying to seduce her for
the second time it seems,
and she moves closer and closer.
As for threats become more stern,
the two women can't even finish without
laughing at the soap opera,
quality of the script,
crowded,
crying,
cry,
and then I say with big emotion,
I drove.
I hate us both.
So a universe of expectation has been
laid out for the viewer.
Will see in a second how those
expectations will work as a trap.
But at the start,
everything in the audition room seems to
reinforce what we already think,
that people are about as stiff as the
wood paneling that he's reading,
partner what he looks like a star of all
my children who spent a little too much
time in the sun.
The director is absent minded and
laughable.
So when the scene begins and woody
corrals betty into his slimy grasp,
what triggers first is our awareness of
how vulnerable she is,
and then when she pushes him away,
we don't know if she's reacting as
herself or as the character than woody
moves to put his hands below her waist,
and something incredible happens.
A transformation so sudden that the
viewer experiences whiplash as the
critic George tolls notes were lured
into engaging emotionally with the
scene.
When lynch triggers our expectation that
betty might be exploited.
We've dropped our guard a little,
but it's already too much.
We've surrendered enough so that when
Lynch switches the bait,
we're left in awe at what happens next.
I.
It's not that difficult.
He trusts you
all throughout the film.
From the overdub dialogue on down,
David Lynch has made us privy to the
veneer of things.
It's all curiously two dimensional and
that puts us on our card.
Since surfaces are what we get,
lynch encourages us to examine those
surfaces,
always remaining detached enough for a
disinterested,
critical view of what we're seeing,
but as with everything that Lynch does,
this two dimensionality,
this flatness is also a deception.
I know you said you would entertain
suggestions and that's all anybody here
is asking you to do.
What are you talking about?
While we think we're on our guard,
superior to the clawing emotions of
Hollywood wish fulfillment,
Lynch relishes dropping the bottom out,
showing us just how unprepared and
susceptible we are to emotions that our
society,
treasurers or deeply fierce in a scene
that mirrors the audition.
Betty and Rita go to a place called
club.
Silencio were a special show is
underway.
The host repeats again and again.
No,
and everything you're hearing he says is
a tape recording.
Expectations for the scene are made
totally explicit.
Then a woman comes out and sings,
a truly heartbreaking Spanish version of
Roy orbison's crying lynch pushes tight
into her face in an extreme closeup,
and the film begins to taunt us.
Hey,
what's at stake here?
As in any movie is belief.
Can the director of make you believe the
artifice being presented to you?
It's why directors use expectations.
We incorporated from other films when
two people lock eyes for the first time
and the camera pushes in.
That's love at first sight,
and this is one way to generate belief.
The definition of expectation is a
strong belief that something will
happen,
but lynch goes a step further.
In one way,
he sets up an expectation than lures you
into believing the opposite,
so when the rug is pulled out,
the audience is left,
suspended,
caught out,
and captured,
engaging fully with the terrifying
nothingness that they were warned
against.
When the film finally takes it's hard,
right?
Turn revealing Betty's true story of
pain and degradation.
We're confronted again with the same
feeling,
believing we're going to get the key to
the mystery,
but instead are only sunk deeper into
the dream and it's worth noting by the
way that this all comes from an
expectation that goes unfulfilled,
but the audition scene plays the reverse
feeling,
and I think this is important.
Instead of pulling the rug out to reveal
an abyss,
we come in fully prepared and analytical
only to be dropped into a space of raw
and honest emotion,
even though we know it's active,
even though we know this is a film,
were entranced totally believing the
moment,
not because our expectations were
fulfilled,
but because they were subverted in a way
that we didn't think was possible,
and now I say with big emotion,
I drove
not content with the dreams that
Hollywood has been feeding us and mass
for decades.
David Lynch uses cliched expectation to
move us into the spaces.
Film has yet to go showing us the
dangers and the hopes of believable.
I can't believe it.
That's a lot of lynch in a week period.
Anyway,
thank you very much for watching.
Happy Wednesday.
Thank you so much guys,
for all the well wishes on my tedx talk
a couple of weeks ago to support.
It just just makes me feel good.
I have to think squarespace for
sponsoring this video.
They do intuitive,
sleek websites where you just go on and
start making one.
You go to squarespace.com
and sign up for a year.
You can get a free trial and if you use
the offer code nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Thank you guys.
Thank you everybody again.
I will see you next Wednesday.